if you want to better understand
yourself and how to better interact with
others
you need to understand your values
that's why the minimalist created a free
downloadable and printable values
worksheet
that will help you identify all of your
different values
and the obstacles that are in your way
head on over to theminimalists.com
v to download your free values worksheet
today
enjoy non-minimalists
how do we find forgiveness from
ourselves and others for past
transgressions so i don't know
i assume there was a lot of you know
self-reckoning
over that 12-year period but a lot of
blame
going on i'm sure right you're blaming
yourself
how do you how do you forgive yourself
for for
making some decisions that literally
cost you 12
years of freedom
i mean how do you forgive yourself i i
i mean this is a question from tim by
the way yeah
uh there's a horrible question about it
because you know it's they're always
horrible questions when you don't really
have like
it's like do you give the standard no
answer or what did you really
you know you kind of got to look at it
and like how do i really feel well let's
look at tim
tim is probably in a position right now
where he's like [ __ ]
i screwed up i did something i wish i
wouldn't have done
and i feel like forgiving myself really
means that's how i'm going to get past
this and so maybe if he were to if we
were to rephrase his question like
i don't know that you completely get
past it though no i think
look you know the way
i look at it is look i can't i can't fix
anything i can't fix i can't pay back
six million dollars
i owe six million dollars and and you
know i've got
i have over 50 victims which are banks
okay about 30 of those banks went under
so i can't make those banks whole and
not that i not that well i'm not
in some way some small fraction i'm sure
i contributed that but basically was the
the um the 2008 crash you know so
it's like one i can't even pay i can't
pay those banks back
right um i can't pay uh even you know
i probably will never be able to pay
back the six million i can make my
restitution payments that's what i can
do
um you know there i have four individual
victims
where i can i go in i convince you to
own or finance your house to me
so you want to finance your house to me
um i give you twenty thousand twenty
five thousand dollars down you wanna
finance the house i then turn around and
i satisfy the
loans on the house and yours and then i
borrow a bunch of money on the house
now i just borrowed almost a million
dollars on your two hundred thousand
dollar house
you get a few payments from me and then
suddenly you get a phone call from the
secret service
hey this is what's happening you then
turn around and you go get a lawyer
because these banks
who have also been notified but some of
them are contacting you saying look you
know
they're starting the foreclosure process
so you have to clean your title somehow
and the banks aren't necessarily going
to even help you so you get an attorney
and you pay some attorney 10 grand
one guy paid 10 grand one guy paid five
one guy paid seven
and ends up i owe four victims a total
of 40 grand i know no of 30 000 30 30
000 so you know and i'm always looking
at like
one of the people there it's a doctor
one guy's a cpa like these are
professional people and i'm like
that's not killing them you know that's
not killing them that's when i initially
think it you know i'm like they'll be
fine they're fine you know and they
probably are fine
but you know what you are a normal
guy living your life doing all the right
things and i come in and i just
smash it all i can imagine
how angry look the one guy the doctor dr
brown
which is the person i'm thinking about
the secret service
said he was so upset he couldn't come
to court they wanted him to come in and
talk sorry they wanted him to come and
talk or his wife
they actually lived in atlanta at that
point
they're probably a couple miles from the
courthouse he couldn't do it
he couldn't he said i cannot come and be
next to this guy
and and and and sit there without
wanting to physically harm him
he can't do it and i remember
when i first heard that i was kind of
like you know
and and but the more i think about it
you know it's like
no he's right
he's got a couple kids he's got a wife
he's doing all the right things he went
to the in the military
he's got a uh he's got a a medical
degree he's living his life he's done
all the right things
he owner fi he then owner finances his
house to you
and you just rip his world apart how do
i make that good
i mean you know i can say i'm sorry i
don't think that dr
dr brown has any forgiveness in his
heart for me
i'm sure he hates my guts he can't even
be in the same room with me
you know i don't know what to do to make
that right
other than to be honest about it and
just be honest that
i messed up i wish i could make it right
i wish i could try
and and you know i'm going to pay my
restitution i don't even know how much
of that's going to him i can't even talk
to him
like i couldn't even go to him and say
hey can how could i make this right
um you know so you just what you do is
you be honest and some people will never
get over it and that's not that's that
there's nothing i can do about that sure
yeah but you just be honest about it you
be honest with yourself
stop saying oh will you this and you
that what do you mean you this you're
gonna be okay
that's none of my business if he's gonna
be okay you know it's
it's just to say i [ __ ] up he didn't
have it coming i wish i could change it
and i just you kind of have to forgive
yourself and you move on because i can't
go around the rest of my life
trying to you know crying about
something i just can't fix
and i'm not willing to end it all to
make the pain go away
yeah you know so you just have to just
move forward i would i would have pinned
it with one thing because i think
i agree with everything you're saying
here because there's certain things we
can't
pay back and or if we really got value
from someone like
a dead author there's nothing i can do
to thank him even right right
but i can pay it forward in a bunch of
ways and i think that's where
what you're doing now whether it's with
your your
writing with your books with the
interviews that you do
you're paying it forward in a way not
only are you entertaining people but
uh to me this is a deeper conversation
um ryan and i were talking about this
when we were taking a break
um you you said something really
profound during the minimal episode
about um figuring out how to be yourself
okay i mean i was thinking i doubt that
no i mean
no it was it really is it was powerful i
mean because
really ultimately the message of what
ryan and i are trying to communicate we
don't express it that specific way but i
love the ways
what we're saying is simplify things so
that you can figure out how to be
yourself you know the word complex
uh comes from the latin root complex
which just means to interweave two or
more things together
you had a very complex life
uh back in the the audies right and
and what you've done now is is
simplified in a way now
initially you were forced into
simplification through
the prison system but now you're doing
something
that is simple not easy don't don't get
me wrong writing i know i mean i've
written
five books it's it's not an easy uh
thing
but you've simplified your life in a way
and i see it as a way to
if you can't pay people back then the
only thing we can do is pay it forward
right yeah do you feel like you're doing
that with your work because i i
i i knew this was going to come up
because look when i was in prison
and i'm um you know
i know you've you've mentioned this
before we had this conversation where
you basically were like i think you're
not giving yourself no credit
but you know i am by nature a selfish
person i am
i am concerned about me um and i think
most people are but a lot of people hide
it you know
and then i think there are some selfless
people that are just out there yeah
um but what happens uh in
is that you know i started writing the
stories because when i wrote my story i
liked it
enjoyed it started writing uh like for
instance devaroli's story the the the
one that
i wrote the memoir everybody knows the
guy from warthogs right well i mean i
wrote the real guy from warren dogs i
wrote his memoir
so i wrote his story because i was
basically
wrapping up my story like i was going
through and i was editing it i was
catching errors and stuff you know
that's that's that one that i
the shark in the house while i was in
prison and so i was finishing it and
everybody was like you gotta go talk to
this guy you gotta go talk to this guy i
wasn't thinking about writing anybody's
story
i just saw him and it's like what do i
do now
you know what i mean yeah it's like you
know how do you know how many times
and this i never knew this at the time
but i see it all the time now
where i'm like okay if i do this and
then i do this and i do this and i think
of all these things that if i could do
to
do all these things then then this
happens you want to know what the most
the worst part of that whole process is
for me
when i get this when this is done and
then it's
immediately it's like okay i got what i
want and now
i'm empty what do i do and that's how i
felt i'm like this is almost done
what do i do right so i thought well he
needs a memoir
he's got a great story um he was in
rolling stone he
you know he he was in you know details
magazine and all you know he he's
let me talk to him i can help him
that'll give me something to do
yeah because so i go and i talk to him
and then eventually he's like yeah you
know i said look
i didn't want to write the story i said
let me write to help you write a really
good outline you can send it to a
ghostwriter
and then as i'm writing the outline he
says can i read your book and i went
sure
he reads my book he comes back three
days later he put he walks up and puts
it down he says he goes
he goes bro that's the best thing i've
ever read in my entire life and i
remember thinking now everybody was
telling me how great it was
and i just remember thinking wow
that's this guy is brilliant he's fresh
off the street
these other guys are my friends they'll
lie to me and i'm thinking
wow that's great now in all fairness
about a week later i realized found out
he'd only read about three books
but so most of these read magazines
and contracts uh so it's in his top
three yeah
so so anyway he says can you write my
book
and i was like he goes this is what i
want and he goes that's what i want and
i went
i mean i don't you can get a real writer
because bro you're a real writer
and i went no bro i'm just some
douchebag in prison who's trying to
raise it no no no
no that's amazing so i say okay so we
work out a deal i write his book
um when he's done somebody else comes to
me
by those before i'm even done guys are
like bro i need you to write my book
and i'm like what and i'm like you know
dev rolly is at least putting money on
my books to pay for like quarreling so
that you can actually type it up i can
email stuff like he's actually
kind of semi-funding the project these
other guys nobody's got any money
so i'm like okay well what do i get from
this i mean i mean
what's your story and these guys tell me
the story i'm like well you
i'm sorry and i know i feel bad for you
and you've got about it and it's a rough
you had a rough childhood you've got a
lot of you got some you're a sympathetic
character you've got some things that
are i could really work with but you got
a very common story
and i'm sorry i don't want to say that i
know how you feel but and you could
write that story and i will help you
write that story
but i can't dedicate my time to writing
that story because there's a hundred
guys here that have that story
so the next guy the next guy you're like
no no the next day before i know it i'm
like screening people
to write their stories yeah this sounds
like a really selfish person here right
i'm helping all these people write their
stories
i'm so selfish well you know what's
interesting everyone's a little selfish
and what you're doing is you are helping
other people but i do
see how you think it's a little selfish
because because i felt it was help
because
it was helping me yeah it gave me
purpose but that's the right kind of
selfish though i feel like it's not
selfish and that
let me let me uh give you a distinction
there's a difference between selfish
and operating in your own self-interest
selfish
is what you were doing before it's at
the detriment of other people yeah it's
it's doing things that that negatively
affect
other people for your own personal gain
self-interest
and some people might even call it
you're doing altruism
is helping other people as you help
yourself
there's nothing more rewarding than that
right i i mean okay i like that
oh let's go with that yeah yeah but it's
true here's well here's what i'm
what i'm getting at is as i start
writing these guys stories obviously
some of them are just synopses like i'm
not going to write an entire book on you
but i'll write a synopsis of your story
i start to real i get i end up getting a
couple
of guy or i end up getting this guy into
rolling stone magazine
uh-huh sorry so because he came to me
you gotta write my book you gotta write
my book i'm like no no he's like and we
remember we were walking
oh i couldn't stand this guy he was so
he's bugging the crap out of me
and i was like i was like bro i mean he
goes bro i'll give you
he goes i'll give you half of anything
that anything the story makes and i go
you're damn right she will i said that
was never up for debate
i said that was always going to happen i
said you're not that's not a gift i said
i mean why don't you
what's your story i said you're you're
here for for running for sell on
oxycodone
i was like there's there's 50 guys
there's 150 guys on the compound whose
doctor shopping is just listen to my
story and of course i always you know
that
the you know opportunity knocks very
softly
you know i'm saying you're a fool not to
listen so i was like
all right fine meet me tomorrow here and
you know and first of all nice thing is
typically if you tell someone to meet
you there like they'll they won't meet
you
and then you get to write them off
you're like nah bro i no wasn't that
important two minutes you didn't even
show up yeah
yeah so he shows up
and he tells me a story and it's a great
story
and so to try and get rid of him i say
try and get out of it i say listen
it is pretty it's pretty unique it's
really good like the thing you did with
this the teddy bears and this
i'm like that's pretty good i'm like i
can work with that
and i said so i'll write this let me
write a synopsis of the story
and if i can get you into a magazine or
something like get you some publicity
because you have no publicity
nobody knows about this source i need to
get you some publicity then i'll write
the book because i'm thinking
no way i get this guy in the magazine i
can get rid of him
right and so we sign a document i'm
going to write it and i get 50
of anything that happens on the result
of the story so we go through this whole
thing
and i say look at some point i'm just
going to collect these stories i'm just
going to collect them and when i get out
someday i'll have the stories
and maybe someday i'll be able to do
something with them i still have 26
years by the way
i'm just getting at 20 30. so this is
just something to do to pass the time
i write the story i send it off to like
six or seven reporters and like three of
them
come back two of them come back and say
this is amazing but i just don't have
time i'm in the middle of five projects
three two of them come back so i can do
it can you wait six months one guy comes
back says i can present this right now
oh wow and i went okay well who can you
we
can do well i can do this so we start
going back and forth he says
i can go to rolling stone well he didn't
want to go to rolling stone actually he
he wanted to go put it on uh
on he wanted to put it on a medium which
is a magazine a
online magazine and i went no no i want
you to go to i said i want you to put on
some blog
i want to go or to be in rolling so he's
it's not a blog it's an online magazine
and i'm like yeah bro listen i'm in
prison
can i touch it and he goes no i said i
want it
in a magazine i can hold in my hand
because i don't want to have access to
the internet and i don't know what
you're talking about
and so we argue we actually got on the
phone and i said you know what bothers
me
the most about this conversation he goes
what i go you won't even try
oh and he i said if you tried and they
said no
i said then we can go with medium and he
goes
all right i'll go i'll try he comes back
like three days later
all right it's gonna be wrong i'm still
magazine that's told you
yeah i'm okay with trying and failing
listen i've been failing my whole life
but i'm okay with trying and failing
just not trying
bothers me